let me take Warren Buffett for example
Andrea totally Frank I'm not his biggest
fan but he does like Capital allocation
and he reads a lot of sort of annual
reports of companies and pretty boring
really um and he's trying to figure out
is Coke or Pepsi deserve more capital I
mean that's I mean it's kind of a boring
job if you ask me I do think in the
United States especially there's an over
allocation of talent in finance and law
basically too many smart people go into
finance and all so you know this is both
a compliment and a criticism we should
have I think fewer people doing law and
fewer people doing finance and more
people making stuff hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I struggled
to stay afloat I quit in my business
partner and the thing that kept me going
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's have your best
believe life and learn what successful
people think about Warren Buffett
speaking of Warren Buffett you recently
spent an afternoon with him did it turn
out that the two of you had more in
common maybe than you thought I think
most people do after conversation you
realize that you have more in common
than you than than you know things that
are dissimilar he's very sharp you know
and and again he just affirmed to me
that instincts is really important in
business you know I didn't go to any
proper business school or any uh read
any super uh follow any manuals like the
record business 101 or anything like
that I just pretty much followed my
instincts and he just reaffirmed that
for me that you know your instincts are
very important to you in 1942
an 11 year old boy from Omaha Nebraska
invested his entire fortune in six
shares of city services preferred at 38
dollars per share
[Music]
the stock soon dropped sharply
devastating his Holdings
but true to form the boy did not panic
he held those shares until the stock
rebounded earning himself a small profit
things got a little bit better after
that
today we know Warren Buffett not only is
one of the world's richest men but also
one of the most admired and respected
unmoved by Financial feds he's doggedly
sought out value
put his weight behind companies with
promise and demonstrated that Integrity
isn't just a good trait it is good for
business
and yet for all the money he's earned
you don't see Warren Buffett wearing
fancy suits
or driving fancy cars
instead you see him devoting the vast
majority of his wealth to those around
the world who are suffering or sick or
in need of help
and he uses his stature as a leader to
press others of great means to do the
same
a philanthropist is a lover of humanity
and there's no word that fits Warren
better
I should point out he's so Thrifty I had
to give him a White House tie
the last time he came here to visit
foreign
looking a little shredded so then when
when Bill Gates came he wanted one too
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there I was in the world of writing
software being an engineer and he was in
the world of picking stocks and I just
had never been attracted to that for
myself and yet as soon as he was asking
me about IBM or Hewlett-Packard and how
they price their product and how things
were changed machine and what the nature
of the competition was
and what I would do if I got to run
those companies I could see that his
investing was just an outcome from
having this incredible model of business
and business value and so you know I got
to ask him lots of questions and uh our
first meeting turned into a day-long
discussion
and I was you could say you know Smitten
by the opportunity to talk with Warren
about all these topics Warren when I
first met him didn't use a computer
whatsoever
however Within
three years of my meeting and by 1994 he
was starting to do online bridge and in
fact his online Bridge was so extensive
that he'd spent over 20 hours a week but
just doing that one thing for for quite
a while today he's you know quite Avid
at browsing uh in his home where he'll
look up currency prices or trading
numbers or various articles so he's a
he's a pretty in-depth browser but it
was bridge that got him to get familiar
with the keyboard and uh get to be
reasonably capable you have an
incredible person doing everything that
needs to be done but it's kind of
inverted where Warren is picking the
business for its Dynamics uh buying
often 100 of it and there's actually
more value in the fully owned businesses
now than in the Investment Portfolio
and because he's picked the manager
who's dedicated to the details the
specifics of that business he gets a
world-class operator he's simply taking
whatever excess Capital comes out and
redeploying it in a business that can
grow its opportunities because of that
so the dialogue between Warren and the
manager is you know it's the manager
still
excited about his job still dedicated to
it so rarely they'll have to be a
succession uh and then the capital issue
does that person want more Capital than
they've made because they have
opportunities or are they generating
capital and then Warren takes and
spreads out around uh the different
things inside the company so Warren does
what Warren is incredibly good at
including picking that person but it
doesn't include knowing the pricing of
the jewelry or the
you know should there be a new box of
candy brought out or anything like that
it's always amazing you can describe a
business tour in 10 or 15 minutes and
he'll know what the key things to ask
and look for are he doesn't need massive
uh briefing on something in fact one
time
only took Warren to visit Microsoft he
was here for the weekend and I thought
geez we should show him around he'd be
interested to seen it uh after so after
we'd spent about a half day doing it he
says now I've toured Microsoft more than
any business that I own
because you know on-site tours are not
you know part of how he does his
analysis you know I've learned so much
from Warren I can no longer tell you
know exactly which things I'm just
following the master versus uh showing a
little bit of initiative on my own but
even Beyond any sort of investing thing
just the idea of keeping your schedule
simple uh
trying to spend your time on the things
that you're good at that you enjoy doing
there's a philosophy of Life of you know
embracing people uh having fun at what
you do doing it with some humor that you
know I'll always strive uh to do those
things uh nearly as well as Warren does
he's a unique leader I can't think of
anyone close I'm sure there have been
great CEOs who understood their
particular company and built something
phenomenal but in terms of breadth and
thoughts about business itself and and
how it helps Society how it should be
done a Warren is singular in my view
Warren Buffett plays Bridge all day long
and goes for walks in the sun he doesn't
sit around like constantly loading his
brain with non-stop information and and
and getting worked up about every little
thing so if you want to operate at Peak
Performance you have to learn how to
tame your mind just like you have to
learn how to tame your body
I love what you're saying um Warren
Buffett might not be the best example
because he drinks like I think six
coca-colas a day and he eats mostly
McDonald's and he's still alive somehow
so it shows you that low stress is more
it looks like
like how old is he I mean he's a fairly
old man with Charlie Munger is I think
in his 90s right yeah he's made it
really far I wonder what Warren's doing
you know I mean just he's got it no
that's bad for him but it's terrible
doesn't care he doesn't care I think
he's just a little stressed yeah right
so he just enjoys that Coca-Cola and
that's probably maybe there is a
trade-off right like maybe him enjoying
that junk food and that coke just ah
that the pleasing of the mind is maybe
better than him just eating wheatgrass
shots and yeah salads and just being
yeah just super worked up about
everything it's like if you need your
glass of red wine and de-stress and calm
down that's probably better than you
flying off the rails I love Warren
Buffett because he you know what he
sticks to the script he he picks his
stocks like he used to pick his stocks
he he has something that there's no
algorithm there's no
uh Wall Street guy that can somehow some
way out think he's got a gut he listens
to his gut I gotta ask you about Warren
Buffett okay come on you spend some time
with uh the Oracle tell us about how you
met him and your experiences with him
yeah I met him over 20 years ago funny
stories you know Warren is just a
gigantic baseball fan and one of his
favorites he always talked about Ted
Williams and and the Art of hitting and
the discipline of hitting as you know
that was one of his favorite books early
on and he takes uh investing just like
Ted Williams talked about discipline at
the plate right stay away from the edges
when you get a fat pitch to hit don't go
for a single or double but hit a grand
slam not even a home run
um but Warren and I met through uh
believe it or not he was insuring my
contract with the Texas Rangers and when
I heard that that story uh I got really
excited I cold called his office uh got
Debbie uh who's his longtime assistant
as you know and uh I mean just like
Warren Buffett like he he invited me
down to Omaha and that started a streak
of about uh half a dozen years where I
would go every year and and visit with
him we would meet for two or three hours
at his office and then we'll go and have
a cup couple hour dinner and have a
steak and because he was insuring me he
would always like touch my biceps and go
you better be ready to go this year I'm
ensuring you I don't want to lose you
any of my money and uh I made sure that
his investment was good with me and at
the end of every dinner he always made
me uh drink one of the the baked ice
cream sundaes which we had a lot of fun
doing
oh yeah I mean you know we were not
going to talk about his diet right
um but on the other hand he's got
longevity so I'm not going to argue with
it so Berkshire shareholder can I ask do
you ever go to the meetings I've gone to
several meetings I really really enjoy
um listening to him and Charlie Munger
and the fact they can sit out there for
hours and hours and just answer every
question at their age is fascinating uh
but absolutely a big fan of Berkshire
and been a shareholder for a really long
time
I had the Good Fortune of being invited
to Sun Valley which is like this big
conference where all these like really
huge luminaries go to and that
opportunity to have lunch with Warren
Buffett and Jeff Bezos and um and that
was like first of all through of a
lifetime like unbelievable like two of
the greatest minds and I asked
Jeff Bezos a question to
um about Warren Buffett I said Jeff in
front of Warren what's the best advice
that Warren Buffett ever gave you
and he said
and they've been friends like 10 years
and he tells me the story and he says
one day I called Warren Buffett and I
say Warren like you're like the second
richest guy in the world he like they
they're talking and he's like your
investment thesis is so simple like if
you're the second versus guy in the
world your best investment thesis so
simple like why isn't everyone just
copying you and Warren Buffett replies
he goes because no one wants to get rich
slow and
um
you know I'm just a Yankee would you
give I need you some advice I want to be
a good baseball player and you know do
really well after another plan and he
said yeah I have two advice
my father please call me Warren and I
said okay he said
he said tip number one be the best
baseball player in eBay
and number two be the nicest gentleman
you can be
and we'll put that down real quick
but that was it it was very simple and
you know I try to live that by advice
that one gave me to this day and it
certainly will change
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
because you made it this far new video I
want to celebrate you most people start
and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see
what successful people think about Elon
Musk check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I
wouldn't say much we we spoke probably
for 20 minutes in total not purely
privately because there's other people
around but that just barely gets you to
know the surface of someone like musk
because he's an amazing person and God
only knows what's up with him